I've been getting some weird gifts from
just koala gave me a Brazilian spray
didn't get it out of the blue you wanted
it I understand that I Whitney Cummings
was wearing a Brazilian spray yeah akka
month ago I know what that is it's some
sort of [ __ ] body spray yeah like you
know have you guys ever used I use a
lotion called a bum bum cream yeah it's
like a Brazilian brand and I love it and
he comes home one day and he's like
Whitney Cummings smelled really good
today and I want the same you know one
same body spray yeah yeah so I got him
the same body spray yeah but I didn't
understand that but I didn't want it for
my birthday gift hey do you want a blob
boy sing it again
sing it again
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god ice cream cake no no that's
I wanted ice cream I requested that
anyway I know that's what she told us
she that's why she took you to dessert
you're like can you please take him to
dessert that was another strange thing
like why would you're like you can't
really want to come home or you're
saying you you would say you're getting
diabetes or some sort of thing and I'm
like I can get desserts my Bert that's
great
so I got that I got a spray thank you
for the spray babe and then I also got a
gift from Warner Brothers right so
Warner Brothers at CAA Warner Brothers
delivered to my house very fancy it came
to the pecans in a box I'm like yeah
yeah there now this is I got the
brilliant spray I'm grateful for that
but this is where this is where the real
[ __ ] is I open it up right and I'm
grateful so you know Warner Brothers or
whoever is involved you know in its it's
a carrying case for suits I've seen you
wear so many sighs I know but it you
know it liked for travellers and I think
this is just the thing that they give
actors male because they think that we
were all we're soon a stock like a stock
OS they have a whole warehouse of like
oh here's our male actors yeah so this
year it's all suit suit carrying cases
yeah right so I got that which I'll
never use the thank you thank you I
think who gave me this dream water
that's just hiring our stuff yeah do you
order powder for me yes where is it it's
in the mail alright so this is what you
got you got this at the store for me yes
sir this is your gift to me
mm-hmm thank you George it's up it's
probably 52 it's up there well what'd
you get
it's coming it's in the mail are you
talking about it only one person could
use that excuse all right I can't use
the mail excuse and I will I will not be
angry if you're just completely and
utter an Asst with me
right now just say just I'll see what I
got yeah this is not your gift but I did
get it is the waters the boughs the
balloons and the blow up balloons the
glow in the light balloons oh and the
obvious so um beyond so rice would you
get me
[Music]